et il ya eu un superbe outil tchèque
mais le carif eric selah sue même nadège
et fait pas mieux que tu parles mon
camarade isabelle isabelle sûr qu'il a
décidé
les sur vous dans quelques instants oui
ça s'énerve et sinon n'est dit dans
l'émission est troisième pour tf1 c'est
une catastrophe
c'est la première chaîne d'europe
troisième est alors mes deux frères ils
sont encore une fois ils partent avec
ils partent avec sa complète d'avant
surtout les zones minières manchette
vous faites un saut m il partage sa
campagne d'avant vous mettez vous mettez
louis la brocante est troisième c'est
possible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que celui ci les idées
notamment pour isabelle morini bosc et
j'ai un devoir moral notamment pour sa
famille qui me l'a confie le body alors
je ne veux pas mais ça va être très
compliqué que mon niveau de jeu ça va
être impliqué